most bodies have been removed and the
ones that are left have yet to be picked
up
each has to be photographed and
documented
the dead are silent witnesses to what
happened here
and what is alleged to have happened is
russian soldiers attacking civilians
fleeing the city
the mayor of key visited butcher to show
solidarity and express anger
is genocide genocide of ukrainian
population
more than sure is that people in russia
and the russian government have to
pay for that painful price officials are
gathering evidence and will submit their
findings that may well form the basis of
a war crimes investigation
i'm a witness because i was here today
we finally have opportunity to register
what happened here
all this will become evidence in our
case
in the outskirts of butcher russian
forces shelled houses
the residents say they were effectively
held hostage
the russians broke into our houses and
took him over they told us not to go out
at night
on the main road leading into butcher
this russian convoy of heavily armoured
vehicles lies completely destroyed it
stands testament to the ferocity of the
fight
the town was retaken by ukrainian forces
on the 31st of march
it's only now that what happened here
can be documented
so far the municipality has found 300
bodies but as they search the town that
figure could rise much higher
i've counted at least 10 dead bodies
down this road they're waiting to be
picked up they'll be taken to the morgue
where they'll be recorded and eventually
even picked up perhaps by their loved
ones
although the bodies will be removed from
this road the scars that this town is
feeling will take a lot longer to heal
as will the cleanup
griggery tries to sweep away some of
their debris but it's almost futile
he tries anyway but the scale of
destruction is simply too much
so what's happening now is the
ukrainians are now going from house to
house which will take them a very long
time to do to clear the houses of any
kind of booby traps that the russians
may have left behind but what they're
also looking for is more casualties more
dead bodies that may well be trapped in
those buildings that figure that the
mayor has been talking about of butcher
of two to three hundred bodies that
figure is likely to be much higher once
the full and final investigation is
released
okay thank you for that update imran
khan there for us in keeve
well we just heard the mayor of kiev
accusing russia of genocide well
president vladimir zelinsky made the
same claims to u.s networks
elimination of the whole nation and the
people
we are the citizens of ukraine we have
more than 100 nationalities this is
about the
destruction and extermination of all
these nationalities we are the citizens
of ukraine
and we don't want to be subdued to the
policy of russian federation this is the
reason we are being
destroyed
and exterminated and this is
happening in the europe of the 21st
century so this is the torture of the
whole nation
let's go to mike hanna who's live for us
in washington dc mike give us a bit more
detail about where and what zelensky had
to say and what's the reaction been to
his comments in the u.s
well president zielenski speaking there
in an interview with the u.s network
making very clear his belief that what
has happened in ukraine does constitute
genocide he makes mention there
that ukraine has 100 nationalities as he
puts it and each and every one of these
nationalities have been targeted for
extermination in his view by the russian
forces uh president zielenski also
making clear that approbation and
criticism should not just be directed at
russian president vladimir putin who's
directed this operation but also at the
commanders on the ground who are
following orders and who president
zielinski says are equally guilty of war
crimes and genocide with regards to the
united states president zielinski saying
that he deeply appreciates u.s
assistance but he says he's still
looking for security guarantees from the
u.s which have not been forthcoming the
u.s secretary of state tony blinken uh
responding as well to the latest footage
that has emerged from ukraine
particularly around that area of butcher
that imran was reporting about a short
while ago saying that this is like a
punch to the gut now this was a
sentiment echoed by a number of western
administrations and governments the eu
criticizing this action in particular as
do the foreign ministers of france and
germany so wholehearted condemnation of
the russian operations in ukraine but
particularly this action near the
capital of kiev in which it would appear
uh hundreds of civilians have been
killed by russian forces
okay thank you for that my canada for us
in washington let's get reaction from
moscow we can speak to hashem ahabara
who is there
what what if anything have we heard from
russia on these allegations has have
they made any response
yes there's been a statement from the
russian ministry of defense dismissing
the reports about
mass murder in butcher they say that
the footage coming out from there is a
provocation and they also said in a
statement
that when they took over butcher people
were given access to leave the area in
including towards
the north towards belarus they also say
that their forces left butcher on the
30th of march
and that before that the ukrainians were
to blame for massive shelling of the
southern outskirts of butcher and i have
to say that since the start of this
military operation the russians have
been saying that they're
facing an unprecedented
misinformation disinformation war and
they have been accusing the west the
americans for deflecting the attention
on the core issues that russia has been
dealing with and they say that we've
been telling them that we have huge
concerns about
the military situation and in ukraine
but those parties were in complete
denial about
realities on the ground
hashem a habara there for us in moscow
elsewhere in the ground russian missiles
have struck near the southern port of
odessa which is ukraine's main naval
base russia says it destroyed an oil
refinery and fueled storage facilities
used by ukraine's military odessa is a
focus for moscow as its forces tried to
cut ukraine off from the black sea
[Music]
i was at home and it was scary because
the walls were shaking i went out and
saw that there was an explosion near my
home and i saw the tank farm burning it
was a big explosion like if an airplane
crashed i've never seen something like
that we need to close the sky because we
don't want an attack again
before it was better i did not think of
sending my family out of the city i
heard some shooting and the air defense
was working in the past but it's not
like this after this i feel scared not
for myself but for my kid i'll take the
weapons in my hands if it's needed but
against rockets you can't fight those
weapons
let's talk to stephanie decker who's in
lev stephanie firstly tell us a bit more
about these attacks on odessa and it's
worth pointing out you actually spent a
lot of time in odessa what is your sense
of the people there
how they're feeling now that russia is
attacking them
well they have been preparing for weeks
this is the first significant attack uh
on odessa at the fuel depot it is in
line with russia's strategy they've been
doing this in several cities across
the country there have been rocket-fired
um adidas as you heard there from the
soundbar you played we've also seen
those air defense red tracer fire in the
sky against them pretty much on a
nightly basis but this is the first time
they've hit it now the russians say this
is because those fuel depots are being
used to resupply troops in mikolaya
mikolaiv is a city
around 200 kilometers away
that the ukrainians have managed to keep
the russian ground forces from taking
and that is the last front line really
when it comes to the russians then
moving on to odessa which as you
mentioned there is hugely strategic it's
ukraine's biggest port and if they
manage them to get that entire southern
part they would cut off ukraine from its
entire access to the sea to the black
sea into the as of sea but it's been
proving difficult in the beginning of
this conflict moline they were talking
about a potential uh naval landing on
the beaches of odessa they have been
heavily mined um but certainly all the
military analysis points to if those
ground troops don't get much closer to
the city that's not going to be possible
i think we're going to have to wait and
see if they're now going to step up the
attacks on mikolayev again to try to
move forward you on ask me about
civilians just briefly a lot of
civilians have left
many have also stayed again that
gentleman who whose soundbite you played
saying that if he had to pick up guns he
would we filmed with civilians who did
not want to fight but decided to take
lessons in how to use a weapon if it's
so needed telling us that if they had to
protect their homes and they and the
city if it came down to it they would do
do so so very much steadfast attitude to
those remaining there there is of course
fear and anxiety and i think today uh
the fact that you know it was such a
heavy blast that really shook the center
of the city will have people much more
worried
okay thank you for that stephanie decker
therefore in la viv we'll have more on
the strategic importance of odessa later
on in the programme